[Music]
on this Thursday night the vital
military mission on home soil the women
and men of the cane Armed Forces will
always be there to help Canadians the
soldiers inside care homes helping save
lives
Canada ramps up testing for kovat 19 but
still has a long way to go what's taking
so long
the rare syndrome linked to Koba 19
putting some children into intensive
care plus Internet giant's traditional
media and money the future of journalism
and the fight to even the playing field
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with a promise the Prime
Minister made to the thousands of people
who work in long-term care homes in this
country usually for low pay and often
part-time Justin Trudeau said in
mid-april he'd make sure they get a
boost in pay but there was no detail
today he went a bit further saying the
provinces and territories have agreed to
provide a wage top-up it will be up to
each province and territory to determine
who exactly qualifies for this wage
increase but the bottom line is this if
you're risking your health to keep this
country moving and you're making minimum
wage you deserve a raise the federal
government provinces and territories
have committed to spending four billion
dollars on the top up it's unclear who
exactly will get it and when they'll get
it what is clear is that people in
Canadian long term care homes have
suffered the most in this pandemic 81
percent of deaths from Kovach 19 are
linked to care homes hundreds of staff
of tested positive some have died
there's such a shortage of staff now
soldiers are looking after seniors in
multiple care homes in Quebec more than
1,000 troops are supporting 20 long-term
care facilities and that number is
expected to grow by mid-may in Ontario
256 members are helping in five
long-term care homes in Pickering
Toronto and Brampton this kind of work
is not what members of the Armed Forces
signed up for it's not what they're
trained for but as Mike Armstrong
reports they found themselves on a new
front line there is no way to know how
many people have died at this montreal
seniors residence the provincial
government stopped making those numbers
public last week at that point they'd
lost close to 50 residents and Thursday
morning the funeral home van was again
taking away a body it is according to
the soldiers now assigned to this
facility something they're getting used
to each residences military team is
split into three units doing eight-hour
shifts there on-site 24/7 most of this
group is from an armoured regiment this
isn't how they normally be dressed
misson this aside super Brendon Susi
calls it strange but necessary and says
the troops are very careful at last
count this facility had close to 200
kovat 19 cases about two-thirds of the
entire facility they were severely short
of staff and what they did have was
overwhelmed at times how much of the
soldiers helped we can breathe a bit
says not cynically show it's a huge
support now for most of the troops what
they're doing is completely new but each
team does have Canadian Armed Forces
medical personnel attached to do that
the forces had to pull in medical
personnel from across the country
meaning the normal support on bases
right now is bare-bones we are all in
and going as quickly as possible in
support of this endeavour most regular
positions in a long-term care facility
take about 700 hours of training the
soldiers have gotten about 5 their tasks
are not medical but for some they can
include moving and even cleaning seniors
many of the things orderlies might do
but there is concern some might have
emotional difficulty in a setting where
people are dying we've put some measures
in place to make sure that guys can talk
about what you see and how they feel so
there are resources available for for us
the forces are not releasing numbers on
how many soldiers contract kovat 19
citing security concerns but the federal
Defense Minister does admit coming out
of this crisis there may be changes
supporting Canadians in the future could
mean the forces need more troops trained
for medical emergencies Mike Armstrong
Global News Montreal in Ontario about
three-quarters of the people who have
died from Kovac 19 are residents in
long-term care there are outbreaks
reported in 225 facilities now and 681
deaths have been reported Ontario's
premier said again today the system
needs to be fixed
we know the system's broken but we're
gonna have a complete review not not
just a long-term care I think the whole
system of government there's better ways
of doing things we've all seen it more
efficient ways of doing things
and there's definitely going to be a
review here's the picture across the
country right now Quebec continues to
have the most cases and the most deaths
from kovat 19 more than 35,000 people
have tested positive in Quebec that's an
increase of more than 900 today more
than 2,600 people are known to have died
from Kovac 19 in Quebec Ontario added
nearly 400 new cases today it brings the
total there to over 19,000 more than
1,400 people have died in Ontario
Newfoundland and Labrador reported two
new cases today after five straight days
of no new ones BC in Ontario of
announced plans to resume elective
surgery the pandemic has caused a huge
backlog 30,000 people in BC had their
non-urgent scheduled surgeries canceled
because of kovat 19 some will restart on
May 18th but it could take up to two
years to work through the whole backlog
BC plans to hire 400 nurses plus more
surgeons anesthesiologists and cleaning
staff and eventually conduct surgery in
the evenings and on weekends it plans to
have operating rooms back at full
capacity by June right now we're at
about 4600 emergency room visits a day
from the previous average of about 6,500
so people are reluctant at times to come
to hospitals so we have to we have to
prepare for that this was a very
difficult decision to make the right
decision to make but as we made it we
were mindful that these were not just
numbers on spreadsheets these were human
beings
health officials in Ontario say could
take weeks or months to work through the
backlog there and medical staff will be
asked to undertake virtual consultations
and to operate on weekends hospitals
will also need to ensure they keep 15%
capacity to respond to a possible surge
in Kovac 19 cases and ensure there's a
30 day supply of PPE for frontline
health care workers the Quebec
government has again pushed back the
date for reopening elementary schools
daycares and businesses in the Montreal
area it won't happen now until May 25th
Quebec Premier says Montreal's hike ovid
19 infection rate and the lack of staff
in the healthcare system
or that provinces biggest challenges
Montreal has more confirmed cases of the
virus than any other Canadian city there
is a confirmed outbreak of kovat 19 at
another Canadian meat processing plant
this one in Ontario the union
representing workers at Maple Lodge farm
says 25 workers tested positive for the
virus and one has died internal
documents obtained by Global News show
the Brampton facility waited nearly
three weeks before publicly disclosing
the first kovat 19 case the poultry
processing plant is still open but with
safety measures in place testing lots of
testing is key to being able to safely
reopen the economy and identify and
contain any new outbreaks today Canada
reached a testing milestone more than 1
million people have now been tested for
koban 19 though as header Urich's West
explains there's much more that could
and should be done at drive-throughs and
other testing sites across the country
testing capacity has ramped up but as
Canada moves towards easing restrictions
the need for more testing is more
important than ever when we're able to
see more cases happening in the
community with increased testing you can
see if another outbreak is about to
happen you can see it much earlier and
hopefully we can prevent having to go
into this massive lockdown again Alberta
still leads the pack while Ontario which
struggled with testing early on has
shown big improvement though that
province admits it still struggles to
hit its capacity target each day the
only way we can get a handle on this is
to have a very strong testing program
along with the the contact tracing as
well but Ontario is far from alone
Canada has capacity to test a 60
thousand people each day but only about
25 thousand tests daily are being
performed in the jurisdiction that
actually has the epidemic under control
you may not be testing as much because
you actually have cases and we've heard
from provinces that now that there's no
respiratory virus sort of season they
actually getting very few people coming
in for testing but testing the sick
should only be one part of the country's
testing strategy there should be some
sort of surveillance in different
regions to
ensure that we can detect cases and
areas that so we can detect cases early
enough and pounce on this such that it
does inspire a lot of control that means
testing more people without symptoms
asymptomatic testing is being done in
provinces like Alberta but even their
strategies around exactly who should be
tested are still being worked out and so
even that province is seeing much of its
test capacity each day go to waste we
could do up to about 7000 a day and the
volumes lately have been anywhere
between say three and 5,000 a day
thousands of opportunities to catch the
virus early being missed every day
Heather your ex West Global News Calgary
children have been spared in this
pandemic experts aren't sure why but
kids who test positive rarely developed
serious symptoms there is though a
baffling new syndrome emerging in a very
small number of kids that may be related
to kovat 19 the UK was the first to
alert doctors to it and now Canada's
pediatric society is raising the alarm
to Crystal commencing reports the
medical world is turning its eye to
children a new multi-system inflammatory
syndrome is making some kids sick you
know more than half of them had were
gastro symptoms so that's vomiting or
diarrhea or abdominal pain and then some
of them had had red eyes some of them
had rashes dr. Sanjay Patel says the
syndrome is associated with kovat 19:00
but how or why isn't known most children
are only mildly affected by the pandemic
virus if at all
but a handful in the UK have ended up
with an inflammatory response some
tested negative for kovat 19 but ended
up with antibodies in their blood we
have to be responsible with how we
communicate this it was absolutely right
for the doctors managing these children
at London to raise awareness looking
after children the signal to doctors is
growing in scope the UK cases surfaced
in late April since then this syndrome
has been identified in seven countries
including Canada but worldwide only a
small number of children have been a
fected roughly 130 still the Canadian
pediatric society is getting set to
issue an alert about it next week the
important message for families is first
and foremost to not be alarmed that this
is an incredibly rare condition case
numbers globally continue to be very
very small there have been a few of
these inflammatory syndrome cases in
children in Canada still hospitalization
rates of people under 19 with kovat 19
are low 26 according to the public
health agency of Canada 12 year old
Juliette daily ended up in hospital
she's back home now in New Orleans
recovering one of the rare cases of the
new inflammatory syndrome being studied
around the world crystal de Manson
Global News London a multi-million
dollar investment comes to nothing
coming up why the plug has been pulled
on plans for this high-tech neighborhood
bus war turmoil at the mall what's in
store for some popular retailers
Greyhound Canada is suspending all of
its remaining bus services and
temporarily laying off 400 workers
because of a lack of passengers
beginning May 13th Greyhound will
suspend all of its roots in eastern
Canada until further notice the company
company canceled services in Western
Canada in 2018 because of low ridership
and recently scaled back other services
because of Koba 19 Greyhound says ticket
sales have fallen 95 percent since the
pandemic began construction plans have
also stalled sidewalk labs a company
affiliated with Google abandoned its
plan to build a high tech suburb on
Toronto's waterfront citing
unprecedented economic uncertainties
surrounding Kovach 19 the company spent
years and millions of dollars developing
a proposal for the so-called smart City
it still needed full government approval
but now the company says it's too
difficult to make the project
financially viable without sacrificing
key parts of it Montreal based shoe
chain all doe group has filed for
creditor protection and plans to
restructure the company says it will
continue to operate online during that
restructuring and it intends to reopen
its stores once restrictions associated
with the pandemic are lifted although it
has about 8,000 employees and manages
about 700 shoe stores and Neiman Marcus
the one hundred and twelve year old u.s.
luxury department store chain has filed
for bankruptcy protection a company was
already saddled with debt the health
crisis has only made it worse it's
closing 43 stores the bankruptcy filing
is a blow to the Canada Pension Plan
Investment Board which was part of a six
billion dollar deal to buy Neiman Marcus
in 2013 on Monday US clothing company
j.crew also filed for bankruptcy
analysts expect 100,000 stores could
close by 2025 accelerated by the
pandemic the struggling retail industry
is one sector fueling the US jobless
rate more than 33 million Americans have
now filed for unemployment aid in seven
weeks since the outbreak began of that
number three point two million people
filed just in the last week
Dead or Alive still ahead the big debate
over big oil in Canada
all kinds of people are out of work
because of this pandemic and multiple
industries are suffering including the
oil and gas sector weeks ago Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau promised federal
help was on the way some has been
delivered to clean up orphaned well
sites and there's pressure to leave it
at that
the leader of the Green Party says oil
is dead the bloc québécois leader
doesn't believe Alberta's oil sands
should be bailed out it is a hot topic
Abigail Beeman has been following the
reaction tonight Abigail let's begin
with the prime minister well Donna
Global News asked the Prime Minister if
he shared the sentiments of those
politicians and he was unequivocal I
don't share that assessment
we need to support Albertans and and
other people working in the energy
sector through this incredible difficult
time he gave a similar answer in
committee this afternoon a Conservative
MP asked a question about the block and
Greene comments in a way Elizabeth May
didn't like and we got one of the first
examples of what heckling virtually
looks like will the Prime Minister stand
up for Canada's energy workers or does
he agree with the fringe left and those
who want to destroy our country I
believe that the language that the
Honourable member just used is on
parliamentary we can have differences of
opinion but it is absolutely meanwhile
in Alberta the premier focused his
response on the bloc québécois the
leader of the bloc québécois seems to be
obsessed with attacking it the people of
Alberta for having generated an enormous
amount of wealth that we have shared
willingly with our fellow Canadians and
particularly with our fellow Canadians
in the province of Quebec like I said
hot topic Abigail the Prime Minister
also talks about the need to transition
to green energy and to lower emissions
so how is the oil industry reacting to
what he says well Donna the Canadian
Association of Petroleum Producers tells
Global News they were happy with
Trudeau's answer they felt the oil
industry was supported but they also say
no one knows where that industry will be
in a year from now in a recent earnings
call the CFO of Shell said they don't
even know if demand devastated during
the pandemic will come back stay
the Canadian Association of petroleum
producer says that's still a far cry
from a dead industry you know I think
it's a foolish thing to say when every
single Canadian can look at their
personal circumstances on a daily basis
and how it's been touched by the moving
of transportation movement of goods the
food we eat all of it is reliant on oil
and gas but today Elizabeth may double
down on those comments writing a
magazine op-ed with the headline the
reports of oils death are not greatly
exaggerated Donna
all right Abigail Beeman in Ottawa thank
you
next fighting for the future of news
[Music]
when a major news event happens
Canadians expect journalists to be there
and during times of crisis like a
pandemic people turn to news
organizations they know and trust
ratings are up across the board right
now but ad revenue is plummeting
Kovach 19 has sped up a problem that's
been plaguing the industry especially
newspapers for years though as Eric
Sorenson explains two international tech
giant's are still reaping rewards at a
time when journalism is so vital many of
the biggest newspapers in the country
are imploring Ottawa to confront
Internet giant's Facebook and Google
newspapers are hurting in recent days
new cutbacks the Kingsville reporter and
more than a dozen other community papers
in Ontario and Manitoba are closing
major publishers who normally compete
have signed a joint letter stating they
are suffering huge advertising revenue
declines because of the corona virus
pandemic and are calling on Ottawa to
make Google and Facebook pay their fair
share
it's estimated 80% of digital
advertising worldwide flows to Google
and Facebook but they don't pay Canadian
news providers for their content the big
Internet companies have been getting a
free ride this executive for Global News
parent company says broadcasting is also
suffering while news ratings are up
advertising revenue is down the reality
is these internet companies who have
almost monopoly status over how
Canadians access
content through the Internet are not
remitting any of their revenue back to
the publishers who are creating the
value at the end of that chain in France
Australia and elsewhere governments are
taking action Sookie so the digital
Giants are thriving in this crisis says
the French finance minister who is
proposing an EU tax on the one I can
assure you that Minister gable is
working very hard very closely with
allies around the world recently the
Prime Minister did not deem it a
priority but now sounds more committed
we need the media now during a crisis
more than we ever have a close ally of
the Prime Minister on free trade and
president of unifor which represents
some global news employees Jerry Diaz is
critical of Ottawa's foot-dragging on
Internet companies Facebook declined to
comment though some social sites do also
drive consumers to Canadian news sites
but by not paying taxes here or for
content internet Titans are not
recognizing their obligations as this
journalism authority to acknowledge the
fact that they are basically taking away
the product at the same time as our
product our news product is more in
demand than ever
media businesses are facing a deeper
threat to their bottom line than ever
and media companies bottom line is just
one of many the government must deal
with these days
Eric Sorenson Global News Toronto and
that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna fries and we leave
you tonight with a salute from the skies
this is how the Canadian Forces
snowbirds say thank you they're doing
flyovers across the country it's called
Operation inspiration dedicated to those
doing their part to fight the spread of
kovat 19 thanks for watching take care
of yourselves bye bye
[Music]